こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆様は金属を歩いている時にちょっと
変わったお家とか見たことありません
でしょうかそうですね東京のとあるあの
住宅街なんですけれども
ご覧くださいもう
ね至って普通の住宅街なんですけれども
まあほんと一般的な住宅街にいるんだけど
普通のいいですかお店があったりとか人が
住んでいる住宅街なんですけれどもあの
ちょっとネットとかで
話題になってたやばい建物があると
言われている
街でございます行ってみましょうかマジで
普通ですよねでもここ右に行ったらもう
あるということで早速行ってみたいと思い
ます
[音楽]
絶対あれです
一角にあれあるんですよちょっと近寄って
みましょう
誰かが住んでいらっしゃるということなん
ですけれどもあの本当が
選ばず言うと
怖いです
怖いですよねどう見てもパッと
目に入るとか怖いっていう印象があるん
ですね
朝倉画廊と
書いてありますどうしてこうなったん
でしょうか
書いてありますかやばい建物あるっていう
情報を聞いただけで
公共来たので実はこの建物何も知らないの
で早速突撃してみたいと思います
そもそもどんな人が住んでいてなぜこんな
ことになっているのかその謎を解き明かし
ていきたいと思います行ってみましょうお
休みますね出る可愛いベル可愛い押します
ね
倒せないんかい何も
チックの画像がちゃんと言葉として
書いてあります
信徒です
ノックしてみたいと思います
どこ
読めばいいんですけどすいません
こんにちは
初めまして外れしゃちょーと申します
[音楽]
今日
入ってみてもいいですかありがとうござい
ますじゃあ
入ってみます失礼します
[音楽]
すごいすごいすごいすごいすごい失礼し
ます
すごいですねお邪魔しますいや
すごい髪の毛も
うわーこれも踏んじゃって
これちんこではない
爆弾なるほどいやーちょっと何を映して
いいのか探します
うわーすごいこれも踏んでいいんですか
誰が誰だかまピンクですねというわけで
今日はよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
お一人で1人です
なぜなぜ
作ろうと思われたんですか
すごい家があるっていう情報だけで今日来
てしまってまして実は何も知らない状態で
これもあれですか
[音楽]
美術館みたいな自宅あじゃあお住まいに
なられてるということで
ご一緒に住んでもいいですかあ本当ですか
僕今日1日一晩ですねここに
住んでみたいと思います
いやなんかこれだけピンクのものが多いと
心配になりますあ心配になるはいあんまり
こんなピンクにビビットのピンクに触れる
ことあんまりないんでちょっと人がいる
だけでもなんか精神状態が
変わったりしそうなので
[音楽]
もうずっと住まれてるんですか
6年ぐらいですか何かこう心境に変化とか
ありましたか
なんかでも元気でいました
元気になるんですかちょっと特別にエンド
シーさんの許可がいただけたということで
一晩ここに泊まってみたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
先生早速ちょっとルームツアーして
いただいてもいいでしょうかさよろしくお
願いします
台所
[音楽]
実際にちょっと失礼します
野球ボールの断面が半分にされて9ボール
が大量にいやーん
あ本当だちゃんと出るライフラインを
しっかりあ
ラブライブがお好きなんですかこれは初期
のラブライブほのかちゃんですねあこれは
ニャル子さんですかね
ニャル子さんのピンクになってる
すごいなもうほんとピンクづくし結構先生
アニメお好きなんですか
失礼します
あるんですか
すごい開いてる開いてる
あここがトイレと黒
先生あフックで止める感じのトイレなんだ
あなるほどなるほどこれで止めてもらえば
こうなるんであこう
[音楽]
あーなるほどなるほど
トイレもすごい天井までピンクだいや
すごいそしてピカソだらけ
気にしました先生あでこっちが
シャワールームここがシャワールーム
すごい端の
方で
入ってもらわないとの
びしょ
銭湯行ってきますちょっと
闇系のイラストというか女の子が書いて
あるなのでここがバスルームということ
ですねこっちがアート部屋なるほどこれで
もう
自分で先生が作られたのがすごいですね
どれくらい時間がかかったんですか10年
ぐらいですかもう10年作り続けて徐々に
この形になってたっていうことです
天井がねすごいんだよもうお菓子の空き箱
が大量にでこれが先生のおばあちゃん
[音楽]
祭壇
鳴らしちゃってもいいんですか
失礼します
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
先生どこ行くんですか先生あここ2階も
あるんですねここから行く感じでこっから
あ
失礼します2回あるんだ
[音楽]
もうすごい
失礼しますじゃあまずいこれ気をつけない
とやばいな
え先生
抜けちゃったんですね待って待って待って
俺今日で終わりかうおーすっごいたな
よしよしいや
すげー
階段が抜けてます2回も
いろんな
ポップみたいな感じのですよ諦めなければ
うわーここもすごいこれブランコブランコ
あーすごい大丈夫だ
考えたいときとかに
座るといいアイデガウガ
俺めっちゃ
せっかくなネタたくさん考えて帰りますね
でも2回は結構スペースがありますね
ちょっと汗も足場というか
ということ食い込
みなかなか全部この動画だと見せきれない
な1個ずつピックアップしてると多分5
時間ぐらいかかっちゃうんで目に入った
部分だけでお楽しみくださいここが先生の
リビングをリビングですあ
ガラがリビング失礼します可愛い
可愛い女の子の絵がたくさん
すごいなここで今日1日済ませていただく
といいんですけども
先生はお帰りになられるというか
1回出られます
一人
[音楽]
ありがとうございます下
この空間は多分世界にないような空間なの
でなんかどういう刺激がもらえるかわかん
ないんですけどもちょっと一人で一晩明日
の朝まで進んでみたいと思いますこの山せ
てください
わかりますありがとうございますはいと
いうわけで
えースーツケースにしっかり着替えとか
パソコンとかあと生活に必要なもの食料と
か持ってきましたピンクの部屋生活が
始まるわけなんですけどもとりあえず
いろんな荷物上にあげます
階段とかやばいからマジで気をつけます
運ぶぞ
ワンチャン死ぬからね
怖い体感良くなりそう
[音楽]
閲覧やばはいというの無事になんとか荷物
も置き終わったので夜ご飯食べたいと思い
ますというわけで今日の喜んでますまず
飲み物がこちら15ミルクですいちご
ミルクそして主食がハムデザートにアル
フォートのイチゴ味準備しましたさすがに
この場所を汚すわけにはいかないので
しっかりと
ピンク色の食べ物を選んで
夜ご飯にしていきたいと思いますいただき
ます
[音楽]
いやなんか
わかんないんですけど
明るくなってきただからそんな悩みある方
じゃないんですけどもちろんそれなりに
悩み事ありますよ人並みに
呼ばれてありますよ割と悩み事あるんです
けどもなんか見るものが多すぎて
情報量というかで全部ピンク色で可愛いし
ファンシーなんかなんか悩み事がなんか
明るくなってきた
体の底から
割とガチでも白黒の服ばっかりきるから
こんなにピンク色いいものに囲まれること
があんまりなくて
なんかいいっすねー
[音楽]
よーし頼むよ5年後でしょう34歳さあ
来い
[音楽]
あーやばいやばいこの家のこの花なのか
うわなんか
何でもどうでもいいや
[音楽]
飛んでた飛んでたぶん日付が変わりました
ね
0時501分ですそろそろ寝ますちょっと
色々見てたら普通にも深夜になっちゃっ
たら
ベッドとかないのでこのソファーをお借り
してさせていただくのとちょっとなんか
このせっかくの水色をぶち壊すようで水色
じゃねえせっかくのピンクをぶち壊すよで
申し訳ないんですけど自分でモード持って
きたのでちょっとエアコンも無いんです
けどもなんとかここで寝たいと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで一晩すべてがピンクの
やばいお家に止まってみました本当に
泊まらせていただいてありがとうござい
ましたパッと見やばい家だと思ってたん
ですけども
ちっちゃい止まってしっかりいろんなもの
見てみると本当に凝ってるというかもう
全ての場所に
隙がないこの言い方が正しいかわかんない
んですけども僕が感じた
感じだと
癒し何て言えばいいんだろうなんかピンク
の良さっていうかなんかこの世界にここ
しかないこの家にしかないなんかピンクの
素晴らしさというかなんか精神的に明るく
なれたというかなんかすごいパワーを
感じることができた
素晴らしいお家でしたちょっとねほんと
こればかりは一晩泊まってみないとわから
ない
感覚とか感じ方があると思うのでなかなか
伝わりづらいと思うんですけども多分ね
なんかすごい
明るくなれた俺そんなにピンク好きじゃ
ないんですけどなんか良かったです
けども朝なのでこれ先生が作られたお家
ところで勝手に置くのはこの無礼というか
入れなかったら全然捨ててもらってもいい
んですけどもちょっと止まらせていただい
た感謝に
イヤドンとミュウをお家に置いていきたい
と思いますちょっとわかりやすく机の上に
ちょっと机の上に置かせていただきます
関西の印として訂正本当にありがとう
ございますというわけでえー帰らせて
いただきますまあなんて
言うんでしょう
魅力的ではありましたしなんかそのピンク
の良さは分かりましたけど
明るくはなりましたけどもなんか大きく
こう精神的に変化があったかって言われる
と別にそんななんか大したことなかった
ですというわけで
開発していただきます
ご視聴ありがとうございました
[音楽]